I want to do is talk to you about Freud
and I really want to do justice to Freud
because I think Freud does justice to us
and I'll explain why I mean I'm not
someone who's an absolute diehard
Freudian and I kind of understand all of
the anxieties about his his scientism
and the sheer lunacy of some of his
ideas but at the same time I'm really
struck no years of teaching Freud but
the a modern apprehension of the psyche
and actually there is nothing more
intimate than the way that we apprehend
our own mind that modern apprehension of
the psyche is profoundly indebted to
Freud's really speculative modeling of
the brain of our psychic lives and the
unconscious is a huge part of it and I
really want you to think about I want to
encourage us to talk about the
implications of the unconscious as Freud
contours it for us
so there are four things I want to say
about the unconscious and the first is
that for it tells us that we are not
known to ourselves we are not known to
ourselves and for me that means that he
articulates a certain experience of
alienation we know that we are at odds
with other people we know that we are
odds with our environment often but for
really saying we are at odds with
ourselves too and there's a certain
discomfort or or heartsickness about our
experience of the world if you know
Hamlet at the beginning of Hamlet
there's a really unimportant
insignificant character of course from
cool Francisco and Francisco says tis
bitter cold and I am sick at heart and
nobody knows what it means but really
what it means is that it's not just
Hamlet who's sick everybody is sick
everybody is sick all the time we have a
sense of alienation from ourselves from
other people from the places in which we
live and for it is the person who really
starts to articulate that without what I
think is a really startling sort of
candor and when I read Freud I get a
kind of vertigo that I get with very
very particular thinkers where I feel
like I'm reading something about myself
that rings true and for it is a person
who does that for me so the first thing
is we are not known to ourselves the
second is that the unconscious is both
terrifying and exhilarating
we have depths we have such depths but
there is no theory up to the task of
accounting for the depths that we have
our interior life is so much more
complex than any systematic form of
explanation is capable of providing and
that means that our forms of knowledge
whether we come from scientific
philosophical or literary disciplines
have to have a certain kind of humility
we have to understand the project of
knowledge we'll never really accomplish
or have the measure of what our psychic
lives are and can do and for it says
that for us the third thing I want to
say is that we are infinitely complex
human beings and not just that if I
believe or know that I am infinitely
complex that means that I must also
grant that knowledge or extend that
knowledge to others and that seems to be
a really important thing we might think
about in terms of our social and
political life I spent breakfast this
morning talking as many of you probably
do there the last couple of weeks
talking about Shai Torres and you Kipp
voters and it's really hard to
understand how people behave or act the
ways that we they do and I think one of
the things for it says for us is that if
we are complex then we have to
understand that other people are complex
too they act in mystifying bewildering
ways and I also think that Freud then
allows us to be forgiving and probing
about the ways other people think and
behave the last thing I want to say
about Freud is is that in a way he's
less interested he's not interested in
the phallus he's not interested in the
content of the dream he's interested in
the fact that we dream at all and
psychoanalysis tells it tells us that
we're creative that we're capable of
fantasy but we are replete we have
plenitude and there is something really
creative there is a kind of resource in
the unconscious and in fact it's a
really unruly sort of resource and this
is the very last thing I want to say is
it's the unconscious that makes us
unruly sorts of human beings we are
uncover noble subjects the unconscious
is attached to all sorts of things it's
attached lots of words beginning on the
unconscious is uncertain it is unthought
it is ungraspable it is unknowable it is
uncontainable
it is unexpect
and it comes unbidden that means it's
dangerous the unconscious could kill us
but at the same time it makes us it is
the radical revolutionary principle in
us so in a way I kind of ended up making
a really passionate defense for Freud's
unconscious but I think we all need to
start thinking about that possibility of
the unconscious